Good. So today let's uh try to finish
first the identification of dynamic
systems. There is one more uh at least
one more dynamic model which I would
like to show you and maybe say why why
it might be interesting for you and uh
then we will switch to as we did for the
linear regression. We then talked about
some practical aspects aspects. How do I
choose a choose a order of the model?
How do I choose some inputs uh inputs to
the to the model? So let's do it for the
for also for the dynamic systems. So
last
time we have uh dwelled into this world
of uh dynamic uh systems
identification and I hope well also
during your exercises you got you got
fond of uh of the models like finite
impulse response. It's trying to somehow
approximate a transfer function. it
uh it is
uh relatively nice in several several
cases. One of the the the principle is
that it will only only try to learn from
the from the inputs or or only try to
predict from the inputs what will be
what will be the output might be might
be interesting in in some
applications.
Uh and yet the more more interesting
type of model or something which you are
more used to from your theory of
automatic control and so on is the ARX
model which can very easily represent
linear linear transfer functions in the
discrete discrete time domain. It's
basically the the the same thing. It's
just different label and uh what we were
talking about is how to how to fit this
these coefficients if we are given given
some data. So I guess you went through
all the nice
matrices that uh that that we discussed
uh at the lecture also during your
during your exercises. Uh one more
interesting model is a extension of the
of the ARX model and uh it is
so-called
so-called ARMAX model. So it will it
will be like a like a combination of a
arx and something which is called MA.
And this MA is just uh just
moving moving
average moving
average. So the whole name would be
what?
Auto
regressive
moving moving
average
model
with Exo.
Exogenous
input.
Yeah. In a similar fashion as our to
remind auto reggressive model with
exogenous input was formulated. Uh what
was our what was our
formulation at the end of the day? It's
a prediction equation looked like looked
like this. So now we are adding some
some moving average. What kind of uh
what kind of moving
average? So it's a prediction
equation
prediction prediction equation would
look something like
this. We will keep our past outputs.
That's why the auto regressive.
So we have again this term AI times
some times some past
[Music]
inputs. I goes from from where from one
to one to ah not MN.
Then we will add the new term which will
be a moving average
uh C * some
[Music]
E. I will tell you in a second what this
what this E means and we will keep our
our
exogeneous exogeneous input. Okay. Minus
I from for I goes from one one to M.
Yeah. So if
I if I just cover this part, this will
be our good old ARX model uh trans
transfer
function. What is this? What is this new
part? So
yeah it is it is some error exactly.
So the auto regressive part is this one.
The
exogenous exogenous input is the part
with the with the U. And
the the last but not least,
the moving
average is is this guy here.
How does this error
error look
like? This error is trying to repair the
the the model. The
error is basically
The error is basically taking the output
that we really really measured online in
the in some past. Yeah, remember this e
k to the minus i means that we are only
uh looking in the at the at the past
data. So it's trying to trying to see
whether there is there is some
discrepancy what we predicted in the in
the past and what we observed after
that. So this is no longer a type of
model where you take a historical data
one year of the of the data you train it
and uh and you just just just let it let
it run and uh and predict. This one is
trying to correct itself while it is
while it is running. It's correcting it.
Basically, it's trying to do some moving
average of the of the previous
uh previous errors.
Why why why do you think this uh this
model could be could be helpful or why
uh why would you
[Music]
um what what kind of what kind of
application it would it would
not an easy question. So don't worry if
you if you haven't haven't heard about
this.
You can somehow say
that we for example the
winds
so dead
away there won't be any
for example so we can somehow predict
yeah yeah
uh yeah one situation Okay. Leakage of a
of of a valve. So basically what you
what you described is uh well usually
when we when we do
identification basically on the on the
on the historical historical data we
just uh we just collect the the pairs of
instan of instances of the inputs and uh
and outputs. But uh well we never never
thought about uh uh having some having
some disturbances in the in the picture.
So for example a leaking valve would be
a would be a good good example of a of a
of a disturbance and this disturbance
can of course happen in the historical
historical data. So actually when
training the ARX or FIR models we are
completely completely neglecting uh the
the fact that that there is some there
is some disturbance if the disturbance
is measured. Yeah. Somebody uh puts uh
puts uh the sensor to the to the
temperature of the ambient to to
something which you might you might
think of an of a disturbance. Of course,
this disturbance can travel can become
can become an an an input of the of the
model and uh when doing the prediction,
you might either use some weather
forecast uh to to predict the ambient
temperature stuff like that. If the
disturbances are not measured, nobody
will will tell you that uh suddenly uh
we are operating the reactor at the at
the different conditions because we have
a
different different quality of the of
the feed to the to the reactor. It's uh
it's quite hard to detect but well this
model will will actually try to try to
detect this and learn some some
coefficients learn some coefficient C
that will that that will basically
uh keep the information about the
possible possible disturbances that
happened in the history in the uh in the
past at the at the plant. So it's in in
some form you you are freeing your
coefficients a1 and b1. So the a rx uh
part uh from taking from absorbing all
the all the errors that are presented in
the in the in the disturbances. You are
basically basically saying okay the
coefficients
uh a and b you are learning the true
dynamics of the plant and the this part
coefficient c uh are responsible for
taking into account the the the the the
errors let's say the systematic uh
errors in the in in the in the data
[Music]
Um, it might not be
uh it might not be uh very very
easy easy to easy to train. Basically,
we need a need the nonlinear
optimization uh for it in in many in
many cases. And
uh you might now ask the questions how
do you predict because well this is a
prediction equation but if we if want to
if we want to predict into the past uh
sorry into the into the future we don't
have this uh this these measurements in
the in the in the future. So what
uh what would be usually usually assumed
that this uh that this
EK would follow again some some
normal normal
distribution zero mean and some and some
variance that is well I'm not going to
say it's the best thing you can do it's
one of the things You can uh you can you
can you can do to assume this. So at
least you can assume okay in the mean
case there is no no disturbance. You can
create some sort of scenarios what can
what can go wrong in
um one sigma 2 sigma 3 sigma uh cases of
the of the disturbance striking the
system.
clear
somehow.
Okay, if we are clear on this, so let's
let's go to the to the main thing we
want
to discuss today. Let's see how much we
can we can manage
the let's discuss some practical aspects
of
uh of system
identification.
Yeah. Of system
Um basically it starts with
uh what what are all the necessary
steps? What what is the algorithm if I'm
seeing some black box if I'm if I'm
given
[Music]
given some task?
Uh well there is a there is a device and
uh we want to we want to find out it's
uh it's mathematical
representation or the mathematical
representation of its of its behavior.
So what uh imagine the the situation you
you get our nice flexi device for the
first time and you want to get to the mo
you want to get some mathematical
representation some some model of the of
the behavior. What are the what are the
steps?
try to change one
change one correlation between them.
Mhm. Okay. Okay.
So, uh basically what you are
um what you are trying to trying to do
is
uh is to say I'm going to design an an
experiment.
Whoops. All right. I need to need to
find what inputs I'm I'm providing.
Yeah. So maybe
uh maybe even even even before this uh
wouldn't you actually actually read the
manual for the for the for the device I
guess
right or make a check GPT to to read the
manual but uh okay
uh or you will ask somebody yeah if you
if you will come to the I don't know
refinery or some or
some other other production plant. You
will try to get some some prior
knowledge. How does it work? What can I
what can I expect? Is it uh fast? Is it
is it slow? Uh so this is something
which either you can you can get in some
documentation in some manual or simply
talking talking to people. there are
tons of undocumented things and and
features in in every every plant. So, uh
you'll try to get the get some prior
knowledge and based on that you you can
basically find out
uh what kind of experiment I'm going to
I'm going to try.
Um find
out let's say
UK. So when designing an experiment,
what do what do you what do you need to
what do you need to think about? How
long will the experiment run? If I know
from prior knowledge how many inputs are
there, how many inputs I should change,
when should I should I change
them? And this uh design of experiments
uh is a whole whole study
field which
uh we are not uh going to to study deep
but uh basically
um there is
a there there there is a there is a
difference in supplying uh inputs to
your to your plant let's say in this
classical form as a as as some as some
step or maybe doing something something
more more advanced let's say I I do a
just a just a short short step then I do
a longer step then I do a short type and
I and I
uh get get back. Uh what would you what
would you feel is the would would be the
would be the difference
between these two. Mhm.
You don't have to necessarily
reach steady state.
Mhm.
and and what what will what will what
will be the the outcome if you if you
supply
so let's uh let's think about some some
dynamic plant and uh well maybe
the good
example because how is it at at this
point you have actually actually no idea
uh whether the the the dynamic model of
the plant is first order, second order,
third order, whether there are
zeros and any any any stuff like that.
So uh basically in a if we have a if we
have
uh let's say we have one slow and one
one fast pole. So what we what we will
me measure in the case of a of a step
response.
Well not this is this is too nice. I
should I should maybe say it it looks
like it looks like this
where maybe you are you are used to to
to see some see some uh nice uh nice
smooth curve and then decide like okay
uh if this goes rapidly rapidly up then
this is the first order system and if
there is some sort of a some sort of a
delay this will be a second order
system. It might it might not be even
even visible. And this is still still a
very nice uh very nice noise, very nice
uh picture maybe after some after some
some
filtering. But
uh
so you can get to this to the steady
state and basically you can you can get
uh some dominant time constant but it
might it might not be uh obvious. It
might not be easy that you that you
actually get the get the fast pole. It
might be completely completely hidden.
So what would what would happen in the
case of the of the second
input? Uh so the first one is like
medium medium change. What's going to
happen?
The first part should be should be the
same as the as the step response but
then we will then we will get back with
our with our input to the to the zero.
So it's like start of the of the second
second uh second step step
response.
Um the other one maybe maybe we already
already get get lucky and we get get to
the get to the step
response. And what would this short
almost like like impulse type of input
uh tell us? Well, if there is some some
slow slow pole, the the input uh would
would not even the output would not even
even react to it, right? Because it it
doesn't doesn't have a have a have have
a have this uh this uh enough time to to
see the rise time of the of the of the
response. If there is a if there is a
fast pole
present then there will be at least
something doesn't have to be like
completely visual to your eye. It has to
be visual to the to the mathematics to
the
uh let's let's say some standard
deviation some deviation from the from
the mean
[Music]
um only slow
pole. So it might be quite quite
beneficial to use this form of the of
the signals and uh this form of a of a
signal is uh is usually called PRBs.
many nice uh nice abbreviations um
uh here and uh it's called
sudo
random hyphen is not necessary.
pseudo
random
binary binary
sequence and you should you should
actually test it in your in your
exercise. Well, pseudo random binary
sequence. Why is it why is it b binary
jumps between one and zero? Of course,
it can
be it can be manipulated to jump from 0
to 10 or or whatever.
Um, and uh it's it's it's usually
usually uh usually designed or you will
usually if you generate some random
numbers between zero and one you will
you will get this this uh this shape of
the of the input.
Good. So I I designed the
experiment. I I collected the the data.
What
now? What should what should I do?
Process the data. Process the data.
Okay. What is the what is the the
outcome? What do I need from the from
the processing of the data?
What do I need to find out? What I want
to find out?
[Music]
Well,
our quest is to model. Mhm.
So, we need
to do things we did this
semester. So, for example,
standardization.
Okay. Mhm. Mhm. Ah. Okay. So, so, so, so
this is this this form of processing.
Okay. Uh, makes
sense. Good.
So collection
enter and
pre-processing
pre-processing of data. Mhm.
So it's about uh well okay
standardization seeing what are the
magnitudes of the of the data.
Mhm. What
then what would you do if you are if you
Then we can for
example
create the data set
this already processed somehow. Mhm. So
for example the outlines
are out. Mhm. Okay. We could do
nonlinear regression and try
to look if our data fit some model. We
know for example first order.
Mhm. Look for
which regression.
Why is it nonlinear regression that you
that you do? could be
I mean looking for
yeah you are you are kind of starting
with a with a harder thing. So uh my
recommendation is always always start uh
start simple but
uh exactly we are we are going well we
want to fit the model. So we we need we
need to we need the data we have now we
need the the model. So what form of the
of the of the
model? We can even even choose like like
several several forms of the of the
model and compare them. Yeah, we had
this training validation and and and
testing
data.
So let's maybe let's maybe call it
choose choose choose model set.
What do I what do we need to need to
decide? How what is the quality of the
of the model? What are the features of
the characteristics of the of the model?
That's that's already too too specific.
uh that that gain is specific to dynamic
and and linear model. Yeah.
So these were already already parameters
of the model
in in what sense I I
decide to choose model set it's like
data or the type of regression let's say
type of regression
because for example you can u
For example, flexi was described with
like
multiple with one equation and there
were multiple
like parts of it. One was logarithic,
another was inverse, another was I
believe linear.
So I believe like you can choose the
right model and you can Look for the
parameters. Okay. But Uhhuh. Yeah.
Looking for the parameters is a is a is
a is a next task. But uh you you you
mentioned it.
Uh well, we need to decide whether the
model is linear or nonlinear, right?
We might or we can somehow
how do you
well you are choose choosing them
basically if you if you are choosing a
linear model at this step you are you
are basically linearizing you are just
saying I'm going to I'm going to learn a
linear representation of this data so
you would uh if we do the same uh that
change in
different values output and to see if
the gain is constant or Mhm. Mhm.
Exactly. Time constant. Mhm. Mhm. Yeah.
Exactly. This is what this is what what
I what I wanted to ask like how you how
you would actually actually choose this.
Where are my pictures coming? Okay.
Pictures are here. Yep.
[Music]
Either
we No, no, no, no, no. I want to
do. So let's
say this is our first step change. This
is our second step change. And this is
our our third. Okay. Let's maybe make it
somehow somehow equal something like
this. Yeah. like uh doing doing the the
the this the step change in in a data I
don't know let's say to the value of one
two one two and three or one/3
2/3
mhm because what can we what can we say
then and what you have probably probably
seen in your in
your experiments it with with
flexi. So, what would you say about this
about this
picture? I would how would you think
about it? How would you how would you
assess it?
Mhm. Because of
because if
it's the
change for example in the input is like
the same height of the part and the
output
isn't proportional to it. Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, that would be so uh equation like
this which is just a steady state. Well,
this is a steady static gain which is
like a just a steady state uh uh steady
state equation for the for the dynamic
system. Uh well cannot cannot basically
basically get get this one.
Uh what if
you maybe one one more teasing note.
What if
you what if you see output like
this? So not
the not this guy here. What if you see
this? H there's minus in front of it.
where well it's very nonlinear
right it can it can happen that uh that
that the system is so nonlinear that the
that the g that the gain can can change
it its size it sign while in the in the
first case that we just have
unproportional scaling of how how the
inputs in the how the outputs in the
steady state react to to inputs
uh that case can be can be nicely nicely
solved in with integral control action.
No, stuff like that. This one is this
one is much much much harder. Uh it's uh
it's basically impossible to control it
with the linear controller. So even even
the LQR none of the none of the easy
stuff would uh would work. So that's a
that's a red red alert. If you see if
you see
this this
behavior this one is nonlinear but
bearable.
Yeah.
Okay. But what does what does uh this
say? Well, suddenly we want to here
decide about uh choosing uh choosing a
model set.
But that this means that we already
should have this inputs planned in our
in our original originally experiment.
Right? So there are uh many times there
are uh feedback feedback loops in this
uh in this process. So it's not like
always a always a linear linear
algorithm.
[Music]
Um of course um well another another
example this is may this is maybe silly
but what if
What if we we see this this type of a of
a response? So we do the we do the step
change and basically we just see the the
scaled step change in in our data.
So the it's the change is immediate
or it can be discrete systems
and with large period for example. So
this is
well it's it's okay now now I understand
what what you mean. Yeah it's it's
discrete system all all all the all the
time. Yeah, continuous systems are good
in theory but uh well once we are of
course all the systems are continuous
but we are getting discontinuous data or
or discrete discrete data. Mhm. There is
no need for dynamic exactly for dynamic
model why to bother yeah there there is
there is no information about the pole
zero what's whatsoever. So I mean of
course you can you can say I do my ARMAX
modeling I train all the all the
parameters and this MATLAB Python Excel
or whatever will give you some numbers.
Why why wouldn't it? But these numbers
won't actually won't actually represent
anything. You will you will very soon
find it either in the validation data or
even worse in the testing data or in the
testing at the uh at the plant. So yes,
we should decide whether the model is
static or static or
dynamic.
Okay. What can we what else should we
decide? Yeah, maybe some other other
stuff like uh we will we will get to
this like the
order of the
model. Let's call it
model
order. Uh maybe some something like is
there is there input input delay? Would
we
consider input input delay in our in our
fitting procedure?
Maybe when we were talking about linear
and nonlinear, we could do like the
change from zero to one and then make
course and to see if the type of stuff
is the same maybe will go faster. Okay.
Mhm. Yeah. Some sort of a histories
stuff like stuff like that can can also
also happen. Mhm. Yeah. Yeah.
Um another
another interesting situation. Um
right. I mean this is this is critical
thinking. All of these these things uh
all of these things can somehow can
somehow go go wrong.
Um if we are dealing with the stable
system we are on a on a on a we are in a
very very good uh charted territory.
Yeah. The for the
unstable what can we actually what can
we actually do?
What do you think?
How?
Mhm.
Exactly. Exactly. Yeah. So if if
unstable then basically what we what we
need to need to do uh design uh design
a
stabilizing stabilizing
controller. This is of course a chicken
and egg problem because well now you say
if I want to design a stabilizing
controller I need to do I need to know
the model but if I know to need to know
the model I need the stabilizing
controller. Yeah, but uh okay uh there
are there are ways well at least at
least at least some sort of a trial and
error. If you are in the situation that
this plant is running in for for some
for some years in some in some
production facility it it might be the
case that there already exists a
stabilizing controller. Uh basically
what does this what does this situation
mean that uh we have our that we have
our our plant and we cannot longer
design an experiment in our control
variable. But we need to need to have
the control variable in a designed in
the or supplied in the in the way
oops supplied in the in the way that uh
that our output
is
stable. Control
[Music]
controller. Yeah, the standard standard
picture. Uh what what do we what can we
then do to design an experiment to run
an experiment?
Put it in one box. What does it mean put
it on? Okay. Put it in one in one box.
Good. What is the input?
over controller and plant inside. Yes.
And uh how do we well okay uh so let
let's let's say the plant is in plant is
in steady state the controller is in
steady state and that's that's your
data. That's uh you know the the the the
situation basically basically like this
this first part you cannot really learn
uh uh cannot really uh learn anything
about the time constant about the delay
about uh poles
zeros. So how to how to get some some
data for dynamic identification or let's
just test whether the system it's
dynamic seeming the dynamic in this in
this
picture
changes and we know the exact model.
Exactly. Exactly right.
Uh if
[Music]
we let's say if our if our time constant
well time constant t would be negative
so our our pole is pole is positive
uh we can get the closed loop
we still have the unstable unstable
Mhm. Mhm. Well, uh we we now we now add
some we now add some controller. Uh I
don't want to don't want to derive it
and I and I also do not do not remember
it. Do not do don't don't you remember
by any case how would the if I just if
we just use a uh P
controller if the controller is just
some
KR how would the how would the closed
loop uh was the characteristic equation
Uhhuh. Yes.
times.
Ah okay. Okay. Well I I wanted already
the Yeah. Good. So we have a kr
k I I I was I was already thinking about
you know like the expanded
form. So uh what do we have here
plus k ts + one something like
this. How would it look like? We need
the common denominator to get rid of ts
+ one. You have done this run right in
uh theory of automatic control
one. Uh so what do we have? We have
uh am I doing this correctly?
T S + 1
+ K R
K something like this
or am I missing something? The first one
we saw the first one.
What's the first one more?
one the first uh
yeah controller
we had G GC and G GS
yeah could work yeah so well basic
basically okay we need to we need to
just uh design
[Music]
KR well So the whole question is whether
by choosing the correct KR we can we can
make we can we can push this uh unstable
pole to be to be stable
but should work probably
right. Yeah, if this K is positive,
probably we need a negative K.
Yeah, the the whole thing is the whole
point is uh that
well this again can be can be fitted as
a a arx model. Yeah, you can transform
it to the
discrete discrete time and uh and uh
work out how this uh how this uh what
the what the coefficients of this model
model
are just to just to recall this is
now I write wrote R here. Yeah, this is
now the now the relation between the
response and the and the reference
reference
value and still our our unknowns there
are two unknown
parameters that can be translated to
some ARX
model. Make sense?
Okay. Any other funny example that cames
to my mind? I mean there are few more
but not
that not that uh not that
significant. So maybe let's try to get
an get an so how how can how can this
work as an as an algorithm
uh or some kind of a some kind of a
flowchart. We start with some data
collection prior
knowledge. Just trying to see how to how
to plot this. So we
can design an
[Music]
experiment. Let's try it like this.
experiment
design. We can use
some some prior knowledge for
that. Okay.
Once we design an experiment, we do
what?
We collect and pre-process the
data. So we
have let's call it data collection.
Once we collect the data, we should
decide about the model structure. How
did we call it here? Choose model set.
where we will again use the use the
prior prior knowledge. So now we have uh
yeah we already covered all these. Now
we have the data collected and
pre-processed. We we chose the we chose
the model set. What we
can what we can do even farther? We can
uh choose I think Jakob Jakob has
already mentioned that uh choose some
fitting criterion.
Let's say whether we are okay with the
with the least squares or or not. uh
what what does it basically basically
mean if uh if we assume or we see in our
data that uh we we are dealing with some
gausian gausian noise normal
distribution of the of the noise
then we might just
choose the le square fitting
think these
[Music]
squares. Good. And now if we have these
ingredients, well, we can finally
calculate the fit or fit the fit the
model, right? We need all these three
ingredients. We need to know what model
we are we are fitting to what data we
are fitting and what what do we deem to
be a to be a good good
model. What
then we have our model fitted.
Correct.
Okay.
[Music]
So, let's say test the
model. No, wait, wait,
wait. That's the model.
[Music]
Let's shift it a
bit. We will need one one feedback uh
feedback arrow. Okay. So if the then
what
we can
say if the model is good enough. Mhm.
And also we can for example say that
there are some indications.
We
[Music]
use inversion model for example
like 1 / x for example where this is the
parameter then we can use zero for
example. Mhm. Ah okay. So we can see
like the curve it's coping the curve
curve almost perfectly. For example, we
can values for input like 200 and
300. So we can say
that we can use the model only for this
part. Okay. Okay. So uh basically in the
uh you know good and developed societies
it should be always like the model is
coming with some sort of a certificate.
Yeah. It was trained in in this in this
domain. it uses this kind of uh
mathematical expressions. So use it with
uh use it with caution all the time and
don't use it outside of this uh of this
domain. Mhm. Mhm. Yeah.
And well if
the if our answer to whether the this
model is is okay is no. Well basically
then we then we introduce
this this feedback loop. So we can
either go to the very beginning and
design a design a new experiment. Well,
maybe we have found out okay our model
is uh well our plant is unstable. We
fitted a stable stable model to it
because we choose wrong uh uh wrong
experiment, wrong uh wrong model set.
So we can also get
back get back here and also we
can we can get back to the to the
fitting criterion. Maybe if there are if
there are too many outliers which we
cannot
somehow cannot somehow discard. Maybe we
have good reasons for that. We can we
can select fitting criteria like sum of
absolute values that hap that helps a
bit with the with the
outliers.
Yep. Okay.
Uh maybe the last
interesting thing or the next
interesting thing it's not the last but
is the is how to choose the choose the
model model order especially in the in
the dynamic
u dynamic systems.
How did we how how did we go about this?
How did we select what inputs uh what
independent variables will our model
use? of if we had the static case for
the for the linear regression let's say
h
okay
maybe uh when when we wanted to to
decide uh should our model contain I
don't know pressure plus temperature
should our contain only pressure should
our model only contain contain
temperature How how do how do we choose
this the regressors
for example.
Okay. Okay. So
correlation analysis. Mhm.
Good. The question would be well what we
we have a similar similar task here
basically well how how do how do our our
models uh in the dynamic uh dynamic
world? How did the dynamic models uh
models look like? Well, basically there
will be
some again some some
terms which represent the the past past
data. So so the task is actually
relatively relatively similar similar
here. Well, we just need to need to need
to uh select what what past values would
our model include. let's say the first
and first and
second sample to the past and not the
not the third one which one which one
should be should be omitted and
correlation analysis can can really
really help here. Uh but it's it's not
as easy as uh as it was in the in the
case of a of a of a static systems.
Well, in the in the static systems
basically we tried to find some how did
the the correlation look like? Well, we
took
the took the let's say uh values of the
of the
pressure multiplied with the with the
values of the of the outputs.
observed uh sorry
sub usually sub subtracted the the mean
from them. Yeah, because they they
should be they should be at least uh at
least uh centered. Well, and we we did
the
we made the sum of
the s some s some some s
some s some of them. And
well, yeah, if this data were
additionally normalized, this would be
our this would be something like our
correlation coefficient between between
the pressure and the uh pressure and the
and and the output.
Now well we are heading to something
something quite quite
similar but we now have to somehow do
the which movie was that somehow
Inception and uh also somehow
Interstellar let's see maybe maybe
Inception um what we what we want to
what we want to do we want to compare we
have uh we have some signal signal Y And
uh we want to see
whether
the the value of
this of this of this signal that that it
takes at the at the time K is somehow
correlated to the previous uh point. And
we want to want to repeat this. We want
to do this for the for the entire time
series. Yeah. So well the easy easy
approach is just uh we take
[Music]
a we take a copy of this
signal we take a copy of this signal.
[Music]
We shift it. No we shift it
backwards. Backwards. No. Yes. backwards
in in time
and
gaps. Okay, minus
one. Sorry, I'm just discordinated my
plotting. And basically now, well, here
we have the the copy of the of the
signal at at time at time K. So it's
it's just shifted. Well, and now we can
actually uh do basically the very same
thing as we were as we were doing with
our pressure and the pressure and
whatever whatever the the output was.
Well, we can do the correlation
coefficient of the of the signal in
itself. So this is why the why the name
comes and this name is uh auto
coror
[Music]
correlation and we will
even even
find auto correlation function in
MATLAB, Python I guess maybe also in in
Excel exists where where wherever we can
we can process some some data. So there
are several abbreviations abbreviations
here here today. So the autocorrelation
function we just get the
correct correct
expression. Where do I have some
correlation
function? Yeah. basically some some
mean. Ah yeah mean is what I was what I
was missing missing here
right mean and now we are summing I goes
from one
to one to
Then
no. What do we need? No. I
will I will come here.
I K I K
minus min -
I
okay. So what's what's going going on
here? Uh basically we can we can now now
decide what we what we have done in this
in this picture.
Okay, what we have done in this picture,
we just found out how to do the
correlation autocorrelation. If we shift
the shift the signal, the yellow signal
was just move back one sample. So
basically we got the our original signal
Y and our yellow signal here was just
shifted by by one sample.
But we don't have to stop there, right?
We can we can also also shift the shift
the second signal uh two samples. So
that would tell us whether our current
current value at at the time K is
correlated with the value two samples
two samples
ago. And uh and basically we get uh we
get the so-called autocorrelation
function. I'll show you some some
examples in a
second.
Move. Good. No. Okay. Don't
move. How it looks like? But just before
that uh there is
a there is one more function
to that will come to our help and that
is called partial
autocorrelation
function PACF It's standard standard
abbreviation. It will be almost the the
same as the autocorrelation function. So
if you are thinking about
autocorrelation function, just think
about correlation coefficient. So how
much is the signal related to itself if
I shift it by several several step steps
backwards? And the partial
autocorrelation functions it will
gradually uh if there is a correlation
with the uh with within the delay of the
signal within the unit delay of a of a
signal. So let's say if I take the black
signal uh copy it shift it backwards in
time to get the yellow signal. So if
there if there is a correlation in black
and yellow then the partial
autocorrelation function when
calculating
the the correlation coefficient for the
for the red signal would remove this
this correlation from the between the
black and yellow. It's very crude uh
explanation. Let's see it in how it how
it works in the in the examples.
So our our first example
here is it
s why can I cannot I move these
guys ah now I can move
[Music]
them okay let's see many examples but
maybe
They hopefully they are they are
illustrative. First example we are just
uh having uh this is this is going to be
this is a plot from MATLAB. You can you
can also get it. We just take a gausian
gausian noise. Yeah. So these are just
just samples from the random noise. You
can see the the mean is probably around
around zero. The standard deviation
probably probably around one.
uh the
the equation the behavior of this of
this of this signal is is is like what
the each new value is not dependent on
the on the previous value right we are
just it's like rolling a rolling a dice
any any new attempt any any new any new
sample does not uh does not depend on
the on the pre on the previous one. So
that's
why if we calculate our sample
autocorrelation function. So how does
this plot work? Uh here on the
horizontal axis we have something it's
called traditionally lag which we would
maybe maybe intuitively call delay but
this is really the the values
oops I cannot write on it. So this is
really values of the of the I. Yeah.
What is plotted there is is this this
function for zero it will be basically a
correlation of the of the function with
it with it of the signal with itself.
For value ACF at one it will be a
correlation with the with this signal
signal shifted.
Um so what we
can what we can see what is the behavior
behavior that we that we observe
um at zero we basically get get this
this is this stem stem plot that's by by
default in uh in in MATLAB. Well, we
basically see that the signal has a 100%
correlation with itself or that the that
the signal either is uh uh has a unit
standard deviation or was normalized to
the unit standard deviation and this
function will will always always do it.
It will standardize the the data. So
what you what we can expect to see at
the time zero is the correlation with
itself is is is to have the value of
one. What what comes after there is this
blue band and this blue band it will try
to internally calculate the statistics
what is the what is the standard
deviation of the noise and it will and
it will create here I guess it's a plus
minus three sigma interval. So do not
get distracted by any stems which are uh
which are taking place which are lying
in this in this band. Um what does this
plot basically basically say? We didn't
indicate any correlation if we shift the
signal backwards in one sample in one
sample back in back into the past two
samples back into the past and and so
on. Um in this case the sample
autocorrelation just looks the looks the
same. Um we will we will get get to the
to the plot where where it will it will
start start to matter. Okay. And now I
shuffled these too much by moving them.
So I have to find out which one
is which one is the next I want to show
you. Uh yes, this is the
one, right?
Yes.
Yep. So now it will get it will get more
interesting. Now we will have input and
uh and output. So the input or in many
examples will be just the gausian noise
that we that we already already saw but
uh but the output will be given by some
by some equation. You already recognize
here this is the fear model of the uh
second order and basically it's the it's
the moving
average right moving average basically
even if you if you look at the look at
the values which which we are getting
yeah the so we start somewhere about
zero then we have the uh our input is
1.5 so something about zero 1.5 average
is is somewhere somewhere here. Okay.
What happens? What happens here? The
autocorrelation function if we don't
shift the signal by to the to the path
of the uh correlation of the signal
itself is again again one. This will be
always one. It will be it will be norm.
There we have all we have only one
significant significant uh value car
characteristics show shown here. So
basically it says if I shift the signal
by by one one one one delay uh back in
time to the to the past the signal will
be
correlated with it with it with itself
to to certain certain degree. So what is
this what is this telling us? Well,
basically it is it is suggesting us the
the
fact can I write on this? Yeah, it's
suggesting us the this fact that yk is a
function of uk minus minus one. Uh maybe
let's write
the let's write a short note on
this. Right? If we have uh let's say our
y1 will be 12 u1 + 12
u0 y 2
u2 + 12
u1. So
the correlation between
u1 and u2 well where is where is the
correlation? What what do they have in
common?
Mhm. The the
U1, right?
So and even this this 1/2 coming here
it's a it's a it's a suggestion of the
of the one half of the of the value of
the of the output from the past will
will become
uh will will become one half of the of
the value in in the in the
future. Good. So well in this in this
case this is
the data data suggest suggesting us that
we should at least think about some
dynamic model that is shifted at least
at least one one sample sample
backwards.
Uh again there is nothing.
Well our sample part sorry our partial
autocorrelation function again starts in
the in a in a similar similar fashion
but then
it it deviates. It
basically tries to tries to just make a
make a reason out of this out of this
noise, but it's not very not very
successful in this uh for this for this
uh signal. Maybe maybe it would need a
bit more bit more data, not just not
just 100 samples. I I wouldn't wouldn't
bother. Basically all these stems are
are getting getting close uh through
this uh to this uh to this plus minus
three sigma band of the of the
noise.
Um let's
get
yeah let's get to this
example. So now we now we change our our
model. Our input is still the is still
the same but our model is now a rx model
first first order. This would be the
behavior of the uh of the of the
output. Okay.
Um so let's have a look at our
autocorrelation function. Our
autocorrelation function well what
should it what should it get? It should
sense that it actually might might make
sense to uh to shift the to well shift
the signal one one one time one time
step to the to the past or basically
choose the model of order at least one.
Yeah. So this is a this is a dynamic
model that we have in the hand. But the
problem
comes comes uh comes here. If you if you
are looking uh looking at this plot and
uh you take into account well okay what
whatever is is in this blue band I
disregard I don't take don't take care
but still there are few few stems which
are which are uh uh more significant
than the than than the noise. So you
might be even tempted to say okay this
is a 10th order model or maybe fifth
order or order order model. Yeah this
really comes uh comes here it's sort of
like like an alchemy. You need to you
need to decide based on some some
experience how much you trust the data
how much you trust your previous uh
pre-processing pre-processing steps. Uh
why is why is this uh this happening
here? Um well it's again uh how would
this how would this
uh prediction equation look like? So
the
uh output at time one will be 910 of
output at time zero of the initial
condition one10th of of the
[Music]
initial initial
input and
the and the output at at the second time
step will be 9/10 of of y1 plus well
something we don't care about the about
the u because
well we can we can rewrite this uh
expression we can basic basically plug
in y1 from the first line to to this y1
so we will find out what we have
uh 81
hunds
y
plus and and so on.
So this type of a of a of a model. So
the ax the type of the transfer function
uh sort of sort of models will always uh
give or show us some um some cor some
correlation basically for for se several
several time steps. Yeah. because we can
wind back we can find out that even even
after the 10 time steps our output was
influenced by the initial initial
condition. So that's why the sample out
the autocorrelation function won't be
won't be as good in selecting the order
as the partial autocorrelation function.
So partial autocorrelation functions I'm
not going to give you the the
mathematics now but it will it will
remove the the the if if if there was
already identified uh correlation
between the consecutive uh consecutive
uh uh time steps consecutive shifts of
the of the signals. It will it will
remove
the this this from the from the picture.
So that's why the partial
autocorrelation function will will
basically suggest us this is just the
first order first order dynamic dynamic
system. So this was some sort of a
signal some sort of a signal. Let's see
what uh what's going to happen. Uh this
is wrong here. Sorry, I forgot to forgot
to change it. Uh, so now the now the
input has changed. The the system stayed
the same. It's again first order stable
first order system. But our our inputs
are now well it's not the so the random
binary sequence. It's just jumping 0 1 0
1 0 1 0 1. This is how the how the
output looks like. Can easily simulate
it. Um the picture is uh is is changed
uh changed slightly right I mean it's
the it's the same same system uh just
the just the input changed yeah so
inputs inputs matter right so we
we sorry we we would expect to to see
something nice like here
well problem what
What uh helps in this in this case is uh
exactly uh points like this where our
where our inputs stay really well they
are not not jumping too too far from
from each other uh in the in the
consecutive consecutive time steps. This
one is just jumping up and down. So it
can confuse u it can confuse this uh
this correlation
analysis
um just slightly yeah it's not the not
the end of the day what what we are
getting here well we just basically get
like the the shift in this uh it's just
the
uh sign of the of the correlation
coefficient that's not the not the end
end of the day at least we can After
seeing the autocorrelation function at
least we can say yeah there is some
there is some dynamic behavior there is
some correlation of the past and and
present present values the partial
autocorrelation maybe it it is it is
slightly distracted uh it would it would
suggest us already a already a second
order of the of the dynamics I wouldn't
bother bother here because if the if the
partial autocorrelation
didn't
didn't signify anything significant
after this this long stem. I would just
just disregard
it. The only possibility would be if we
have some really seasonality if
something would be happening in like
monthly cycle stuff like that. Uh but
that's already already quite advanced.
Um let's maybe briefly
[Music]
see nice
behavior again. Gausian noise uh noise
input P RBS should be even better. And
we have some second order second order
dynamics. The autocorrelation function
has basically the same same behavior. We
see a lot of correlations with the with
the output itself. But the partial
autocorrelation is clearly suggesting us
that we should at least take two past
values. So select the second second
order second order
dynamics. Okay. But doesn't change with
the
coefficients. Do I have some more?
There was one more but now I cannot find
it. Okay, doesn't matter. It's much
better if you are having fun at the
exercises with with this. It's a it's a
helpful helpful tool. If uh if you
decide to go with the with the
correlation analysis type of of course
you you will you will be even wiser and
you will use not only correlation
analysis you will also use cross
validation you will mix you will create
some training data validation data
testing data to to to be sure that the
model order you are selecting is the is
the correct
Makes sense. Any
questions? Was it too fast or
too too much? I don't know. Pictures
pictures which you don't know what they
what they
mean. Okay. Try try it with your at your